dans 22 jours seulement ce sera le
premier anniversaire de l'invasion russe
en Ukraine et aujourd'hui Vladimir
Poutine il jure avoir de quoi répondre
aux Occidentaux qui livrent des armes
des champs notamment à l'Ukraine des
menaces formulées
lors des célébrations du 90e
anniversaire de la victoire soviétique à
Stalingrad maintenant wolgo grade tout
cela au moment auquel se prépare
accueillir un sommet de l'Union
européenne c'est demain pour faire le
point sur la suite de la stratégie
adoptée face à la Russie et mon invité
ce soir juste un Massy et co directeur
du réseau d'analyse stratégique et
professeur engagé de sciences politiques
à Lucam bonsoir bonsoir quand même c'est
pas c'est pas un Odin de penser qu'il
choisit cette journée monsieur Poutine
pour faire ses menaces avec cette
nostalgie à l'égard de Staline une
bataille qui a fait 2 millions de morts
c'est quand même significatif absolument
ça fait partie du disco patriotique de
vladim depuis des années même a bien
avant la guerre pour qui permet un peu
de nationalisme russe autour de ce
sacrifice des Russes de l'empire
soviétique de l'époque contre
l'Allemagne nazie et en dévoilant le
buste de Staline en réinvant sa mémoire
malgré des purges malgré la violence
extrême sur son territoire ça rappelle
plutôt la victoire soviétique contre
l'Allemagne nazie et ce targue
d'ailleurs les Russes que c'est grâce à
eux que la deuxième guerre mondiale ces
derniers c'est eux qui ont infligé les
coups fataux aux Allemands donc ça fait
partie de pour justement mobiliser la
population russe qui vit ses sanctions
là dont les soldats sont auteurs au
front
ukrainien et donc pour pour garder cette
opinion derrière Vladimir Poutine est-ce
que vous sentez une certaine peur de la
de ces chars d'assaut qui vont être
donnés justement l'Ukraine par
l'Allemagne parce qu'ils ont on n'a pas
amené nos chars à vos frontières mais
dans notre quoi vous répondre on veut on
vise l'Allemagne ici on vise l'Allemagne
nommément et d'ailleurs on veut viser le
peuple allemand qui est très divisé
d'ailleurs sur la pertinence de envoyer
des léopards en Ukraine pour diviser
cette population là en disant mais
regardez vous l'Allemagne nazie vous
recommencez ce que vous avez fait il y a
il y a 80 ans donc c'est pour appeler ça
aussi pour pour mettre un peu le doigt
sur on sait que le chanceletchat c'était
plutôt hésitant à donner ces fameux
léopards et pour une bonne raison je
pense que Blaise bien passé me fait ça
également c'est qu'il y aura une
différence qualitative sur le terrain
lorsque l'armée ukrainienne en Europe
pris possession aura fait la formation
ça va prendre quand même plusieurs
semaines sinon des mois avant qu'ils
sont envoyés même les chars d'assaut
américain pourrait prendre près d'un an
avant d'être déployer donc on verra pas
les effets à court terme ce qu'on voit à
court terme plutôt ce sont les effets de
la mobilisation de centaines de milliers
de troupes russes qui commencent à ce
masser aux frontières de plus en plus au
cours des dernières semaines donc
c'est proche des frontières on a encore
l'image de l'Ukraine il y a un an à
peine avec tous les chars qui étaient
les longues files près de près de la
frontière pas loin de Kiev là on se
rappelle de ça au Bélarus absolument là
on est
sont aussi volontaires que ça et aussi
la milice Wagner qui commet des horreurs
ça va être c'est quoi l'armée russe au
moment où on se parle c'est particulier
si on lui parle la stratégie de
justement des mercenaires de Wagner ils
vont en vague de soldats et de soldats
qui littéralement ils envoient comme
char de canon des fois de 4 à 14 vagues
de soldats qu'on envoie au fur et à
mesure prendre quelques mètres
progressivement et sans aucun égard à la
vie de ses soldats de ces mercenaires-là
et c'est comme ça qu'il réussissent à
faire des gains minimaux mais à des
coûts humains atroces parce qu'avec moi
encore extrêmement difficile alors
Monsieur Poutine j'ajoute et dit mais
nous avons le quoi répondre mais ça va
pas s'arrêter à l'utilisation de
véhicules blindés tout le monde devrait
comprendre cela et renouvelle sa menace
nucléaire toujours à mon couvert que
Monsieur Poutine utilise la menace
nucléaire je pense que ça demeure du
chantage parce que il faut quand même
prendre en considération les coûts
énormes s'il y avait usage d'une bombe
nucléaire à part la diversité une
premièrement sur le terrain il y aura
pas beaucoup de franchement qualitatif à
moins de visite totalement la capitale
qui serait de Kiev qui serait qui serait
vraiment abominable et autant la Chine
que les États-Unis que d'autres pays ont
mis beaucoup de pression la réussite de
ne pas recours à la nucléaire et les
États-Unis ont renouvelé leur menaces de
représentent si l'armée russe du sujet
l'arme nucléaire et donc on pourrait
penser qu'il y aurait une intervention
possiblement directe des États-Unis et
ça ça serait un coût militaire en fait
s'empêcher toute victoire possible de la
part de la Russie et ensemble aux
États-Unis et ailleurs en Europe craint
dans ce que pourrait faire Poutine pas
au printemps là à l'anniversaire c'est
ce que les ukrimés croient ils disaient
en janvier on est début février il pense
que ça va arriver plus tôt que le
printemps pendant que le sol est un peu
plus dur peut-être parce qu'il faut
penser qu'au printemps des fois le sol
est un peu mou et pour les chenilles de
soutien plus compliqué ça reste à voir
ça dépend bien sûr de la capacité qu'on
a réussi à mobiliser ces troupes là et
d'avoir trouvé les fins dans la défense
ukrainienne et aussi les Russes doivent
calculer qu'il y aura de plus en plus
des propriétaires sophistiqué les
États-Unis demain ils vont en rajouter
d'autres équipements des missiles de
plus longues portées qui vont donner de
150 km pour la première fois où
Ukrainiens donc il faut les Russes
peut-être font le calcul que c'est mieux
de percer maintenant que d'attendre
quelques mois ou séchage d'assurer
d'autres équipements auront fait leur
apparition sur le terrain mais la
ferveur de l'armée ukrainienne est-elle
de taille à la mobilisation russe ou à
l'armée russe en ce moment c'est
difficile à dire dans la mesure où
d'abord il y a toujours ce désert de se
battre pour sa famille pour son
territoire de de résister à l'agresseur
qui est toujours une force de motivation
extrêmement élevée comme on l'a vu dans
toutes les gares en Afghanistan au
Vietnam en Irak et ailleurs dans le
passé quand on est sous occupations on
est très très
motivé voilà pour combattre cela dit
après un longue guerre un an de guerre
c'est difficile aussi pour les gens qui
sont aux troupes l'avantage Jésus-Christ
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de rotations
personnelles
il y a la force du nombre qui est tout à
fait du côté russe Le seul avantage du
crédit il est qualitatif la qualité des
équipements militaires qu'on a fourni le
renseignement américain que le
rythfourné aussi et toute laine
internationale derrière eux c'est ça
l'avantage des Ukrainiens c'est pas la
quantité de troupes parce que ils
doivent protéger l'ensemble leur
territoire contre l'agression les Russes
eux peuvent choisir où ils vont
concentrer leur troupes sur le
territoire
aux morts même dans ces trous pas du
tout c'est la stratégie russe habituelle
comme la deuxième guerre mondiale ou des
millions de Russes sont morts pour 20
justement l'Allemagne qui était plus
forte en termes militante de capacité
les Russes sont allés à coups de vagues
de soldat très peu expérimentés très peu
équipé mais qui ont réussi quand même à
le battre donc merci beaucoup merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]